Jose is with us in California hi Jose
how are you hi Dave how are you better
than I deserve what's up thank you for
taking my car I appreciate it I was just
uh I was just calling to give me some
advice I've taken a you know like it on
my net worth and I'm still working on my
job in faith but I'm just trying to see
what I can do
pump that up get it back up I'm well why
did you take a what took a hit on your
net worth and wanted to take a hit
oh my mutual fund yeah so I'm gonna I'm
at 13 percent right now on my 401k at
work but I just got a merit increase all
people have been that up to 50 percent
and I also maxed out my loss for my wife
and I every year so what would you give
me advice on undo an extra well so the
only thing that took a hit was the stock
market being down because of coronavirus
yeah fired up yeah well I mean basically
it's down 6,000 points out of 30 so it's
lost about 20 percent
how much was in your 401k can't work is
about was around 140,000 it's down to
like 110 later 115 probably not you need
to look again today wouldn't be done
that far
how much is other than that if you get
in mutual funds if you gotta you got
other mutual funds over there oh okay
yes like 401 k's and I mean Ross and
traditionals I have around 650,000 okay
all right well and so if you had you
know nine hundred thousand dollars total
invested you're probably down about 200
grand give or take yeah that's kind of
yeah and so what do we do about that
well mines down too by the way and I've
got more than that invested and so I'm
down more than that
you know what I'm doing nothing I'm
riding it out I'm on a rollercoaster
ride and it's on the bottom of the hill
and I'm gonna let it
line back up and by this time next year
or sooner I think it will have fully
recovered personally but even if it
doesn't even if it takes it a few years
so what I don't really need the money
you don't need the money right now
you're not using that money right now
are you no no no I'm just trying to
you're just a freak out loud because
you're looking at your frickin statement
everyday okay
well quit looking at is so much it'll
drive you nuts okay you don't look at it
when the news is good you only look at
it when the news is bad that's true okay
don't do that you drive yourself crazy
man so here's the thing
in those mutual funds is ninety to
two-hundred if it's a growth stock
mutual funds ninety to two-hundred of
America's best and brightest growing
companies so coca-cola McDonald's Exxon
Boeing Apple McDonald's whatever right
that's who you would find it there now
those things are uh most of those are
down because of a thirty-day hole in the
economy a 45-day suppression of the
economy and so they haven't been making
as much money so the stock prices down
agreed yes
fundamentally those companies are sound
fundamentally they're profitable
fundamentally they hold assets none of
that has changed there's just this
30-day 45-day hole in their revenue but
fundamentally they're still solid so I'm
thinking that a year from now companies
like I just named will all be back to as
profitable or more than they are today
more than they are or yesterday before
the Dow one that I was close to thirty
and today it's running twenty four so
thousand
of that that that's why I'm comfortable
with this it's easy for me to ride the
wave up and ride the wave down because
I've been there done that seen all this
stuff before